Speaker 1: Will CNN become the new Fox News in
2024? Many of you have been emailing me about
this failed. Former President Donald Trump has
been actually suggesting to CNN, listen, if you
want to pick up on what Fox News used to be, you
should actually become the right wing network and
people would flock and advertisers would flock
and Trump would flock. So let's actually explore
this. This is an interesting media story, The
natural reaction you might be saying Fox, CNN,
CNN, becoming Fox. It doesn't make sense.
Isn't Fox News the conservative network
that's been dominating for decades? Yes, but
things are changing pretty quickly. And it is
true that politics can make some pretty strange
bedfellows. So let's discuss what is going on.
As you I'm sure know, Fox News has been the go
to channel for the American right wing. And I'm
using that that particular term as opposed to for
Trump supporters or for fiscal conservatives or
for Republicans or for whatever the case may be,
because it's been the default cable outlet agenda
setting power for the American right wing. And
it's where the right got their news, even though
much of it was actually opinion disguised, it news
disguised as news. They got their opinions, they
got their talking points. But then came Donald
Trump. Initially, Trump was not favored by Fox
News in the 2016 primary, which started in 2015.
But Donald Trump energized a base of support that
included lots of people who were not previously
participating in politics. They were not really
in anyone's audience. And to the degree that Fox
News eventually came around and supported Donald
Trump in 2016, Trump's followers also became Fox
News viewers fine. Over time. After Trump's first
term ended, Fox News and the MAGA crowd were
increasingly at odds. Trump's sort of populist,
confused populist nationalism increasingly was
not completely in line with what Fox News was
putting out there. Although Tucker Carlson is
someone who was and continues to put out that
populist rhetoric and then the 2020 election,
big lie led to a bigger rift where eventually
Fox News got away from the lies that Donald
Trump was telling. We now have learned as
a result of text messages released because of
this defamation suit filed by Dominion against
Fox News that even the Fox News hosts that early
on were pretending as though they believe Trump's
lies about the election. Privately, we know they
didn't. This includes Sean HANNITY, Tucker Carlson
and Laura Ingraham. At minimum, at minimum. So
we now have a situation where the Trump crowd,
the Trump part of the American right and Trump
himself are, to put it lightly, disillusioned with
Fox News. They for a while now have been looking
for alternatives. This includes, for some of them,
Newsmax. This includes for some of them oann. Both
are to the right of Fox News and it also includes
even wackier stuff Real America's voice and you
know, the Lindell TV and all of these other crazy
things. But more recently, Donald Trump has been
overtly going after Fox News, and he even has
suggested alternatives to Fox News During his
recent CPAC speech, he sort of suggested, you
know, Fox News might turn my speech off because of
the things that I'm saying, etc.. So over the last
few months, a new option has been increasingly
floated, including by Trump himself. What if CNN
now under the leadership of Chris Licht, who is
new president over at CNN, who seems primarily
concerned with whatever needs to be done in
order to get ratings up and to get revenue up,
What if CNN, which has been called fake news,
which has been called failing CNN, liberal CNN for
years, What if CNN became the new home for Trump
supporters and maybe even for more of the American
right wing above and beyond just Trump supporters?
In a sense, it sounds crazy, but it is not as far
fetched as it seems under new leadership. Always
interested in what is our next thing. And there
have been a number of recent articles and op eds
and sort of pleadings from Donald Trump as well,
that CNN could become the new Fox News, or at
least a version of it. The idea being if CNN
framed itself as we are the place that are going,
that we are the network that will show you both
sides, but they use both. Sides really to give
voice specifically to MAGA Trumpism rather than
just generically the Republican Party. On Fox
News, it is true that the more establishment
Republican Party people like Mitch McConnell,
for lack of a for lack of a better example,
still have a very prominent role there. And to the
extent that CNN now includes Republican voices,
they are mostly establishment Republican
voices. That is absolutely true.
So the opportunity would be for CNN to make a
slight shift, shift the Republican voices to be
more Trumpy voices, play them up, maybe put in a
little bit of right wing opinion. There were there
were times when you had more right wing opinion
in a more official capacity on CNN. And then see
what happens with the ratings. Now, I have to tell
you. Trump's instincts, I think, are correct that
there is a desire from the MAGA Trumpists for
something more mainstream. And by mainstream,
I don't mean in terms of opinion, I mean in
terms of distribution more widely available
than Newsmax and Oann. So they don't have to feel
like they're relegated to Channel 9000 on whatever
cable network there is. There is a desire for
that. And CNN, even though the right has derided
it as being liberal fake news for a long time,
CNN has taken an anti-Trump editorial approach
on many of its programs, but is still primarily
a corporatist news network. So I don't think
it's as crazy as some are making it out to be. The
question is, is this something CNN is interested
in pursuing? And maybe even more importantly, just
because it makes sense from a business standpoint
for CNN to go more right during the Republican
primary and maybe during the general election,
once it's all said and done and we're beyond
November of 2024, is it still a logical direction
for CNN? And that's a real question mark, to
which I don't have the answer. Let me know
what you think. Is this something that CNN would
benefit from doing? Do you expect that they would
do it? Let me know your thoughts in a comment, in
an email, in a tweet, and then we will follow up.